the world's oceans are under siege
marine life is dying at alarming rates
due to accelerating pollution
overfishing and climate change people
keep saying we're at a tipping point
some people say we're beyond a tipping
point but six miles off the shores of
key largo
and 60 feet deep sits aquarius
the world's only underwater research
laboratory there is no other place where
people live underwater and work on the
water for extended periods of time
the diver scientists who work here are
called aquanauts
and they come from all over the world to
spend weeks at florida international
university's underwater lab
conducting cutting-edge research on
oceanic health
this elite group faces danger in the
elements for the sake of the planet in a
race against time
the research at aquarius is being
conducted at a critical time
aquarius aquarius reef base
that's a roger we got the main lock on
aquarius is the last undersea research
laboratory dedicated to science and
education in the world today
there is no other underwater habitat
doing what we do how we do it it allows
researchers to live at their study site
they can do incredibly long working
dives dives which couldn't be done from
the surface
when you're diving from the surface the
deeper you go the less time you have
when you
live underwater the habitat actually
becomes your surface when you dive
from the habitat which is about 50 feet
and you dive to 90 feet
you're not really diving to 90 feet
you're really diving to 40 feet from the
surface so now what you've done is
you've extended that time period that
you can actually spend that 90 feet
that's where it really separates from
the traditional research or work that's
done from vessels on the surface of the
water that makes a big difference
rainy colleges use it as a base of
operation others want to use it for
extreme environment mission operations
we do a number of projects with nasa and
they say that of course is very similar
to what astronauts experience in space
[Music]
everybody when they're five years old
wants to be an astronaut or marine
biologist i never grew out of it living
and doing science underwater is the
coolest thing i could possibly imagine
what does it take to become an aquanaut
we look at people who have considerable
experience underwater diving has to be
second nature and it's not uncommon for
people not to finish aqua not training
they start to understand that maybe
psychologically
i'm not prepared to be in a confined
environment with five other people for
10 days that's the typical length of
missions but we have done longer ones
we've done 16 day we've done 18 day and
the longest one to date have been 31
days long we've saturated 392
scientists now both you guys got your
mass fins vc deathgate freshgate's
computer check i can honestly tell you
from the bottom of my heart that i enjoy
waking up in the morning and then coming
to work
yeah i enjoy my job a lot it's not an
easy job keeping queers going constantly
fighting
weather constantly fighting corrosion
but
every day we wake up and say all right
we've got to do something today because
what's happening with the oceans isn't
stopping
[Music]
you